can you hear me now I'm going to talk
and you can pay attention to her
are you can pay attention ahead gonads
are useful for their purpose but they
are no substitute for brains let's pick
up the shovel clean out fine thank you
god bless you and God bless the United
States of America why does the media
attack an issue to get primetime ratings
and watch what happens in the sweeps
when it's sweeps week they hope that a
child is molested by a rabbi who has an
affair with a cow it's time for it's
sensitivity training with McCowan and
Giovanni hello everybody welcome to its
sensitivity training I'm court McGowan
and here we sit up in the deep hills of
Altadena
with our good friend who's that mr.
Steve Rannazzisi that's what it is
what's up I love [ __ ] rent is easy
yeah it's the best
absolutely your hairs growing in a
little bit huh it's getting longer and
also I saw pictures of myself today
because there's my anniversary so you
know pictures popped up I think I'm
getting blonde like ya know a darker
than it and wait lighter than it's ever
I think you will have no I'm just you're
not putting on Oh Frosty's in there no
to summer I play a lot of basketball
outside so I think just the Sun oh yeah
sure
you still have red hair I still have the
pictures my wedding are like I like like
dark hair no yeah because not very
blonde my beard yells red in the summer
with the Sun yeah yeah they're a redhead
in a town yeah they I have two ants that
are red-headed that means the Moors
didn't touch them that's right I I'm
telling you it my gets a little Minds
gotten a little blonder too you know
boys just white now man it's all white
he's still the best-looking man of luck
yes there's no more pepper it's all salt
I will I will pour salt Oh Lord has to
throw himself
uh you know it's it's getting there now
it's there's there's pepper in there
because there's snow and the chimney
doesn't mean there's not a fire and
[ __ ] gray here I have a couple now
Steve I do have a copy yeah I have a
couple but what do you like Romanian or
something you're I'm Italian I'm Italian
I'm 50% Italian and 50% mutt my like
it's gotta be slaw five different things
yeah well like every everything in
England but England and then like
coalition German got it but I'll like
the other all the countries that aren't
really free but they pretend they are
Scotland Ireland yeah those other places
yeah yeah as long as I have here I'm
happy about that I mean I'm not I know
you look you look young dude well I just
turned 40 so I feel oh really I think
you're old over that I'm because I'm
older than most of my friends so I'm 47
so most people think I'm like 42 43 so I
would I would have thought around there
too thank you yeah like 43 somewhere
around there um but yeah no I don't feel
that much older I get like I'm the guy
that you were like 40 to 40 yeah we're
just older cuz you've been killing it
like stability wise I'm losing
flexibility that's what was a 38 39 it
all goes away is that what happens I
think it's like that was the biggest
jump after that I've just been like
slowly deteriorating but that's why most
NFL guys in NBA and hockey guys it's
always like 30 38 39 when like like 36
like still killing it signing the
three-year deal and then by 39 it's like
that's the only reason I bought that
fight that Mayweather McGregor fight I
mean not the only reason but like the
guy's 40 years old and he's you don't
look 40
until you look 40 and you don't do that
until you do that in a boxing really
don't look no one knows how you look as
a boxer until you're in that ring right
so I was like oh what is this guy look
like two years retired at 40 years old
is there a step missing obviously there
wasn't but like that was like the one
thing I was like oh he's 40 years old he
could be the best fighter of all time
but
you just take once we miss one step or
you're a tad bit slow and it's [ __ ]
game over but see still he was not he he
still he didn't fight a boxer only
fought yeah I mean it's like he would
have gone in there just cuz at forty I
feel like that's you know you figure
that's the turn you're gonna make like I
only sense like flexibility strength and
stuff is still all kind of my it's my er
yeah all that goes later when you're in
your 40s oh really that goes later yeah
like all of a sudden like well they say
like your strength in this arm goes and
I've just totally cut lifting weights
out basically out of my life but I could
just see I just started giving up like
I'm not gonna do that anymore yeah like
I I just can't lift that anymore like I
just can't live that like just your
weight your strength did you ever work
were you a big were like like a lift guy
I was when I was like a teenager yeah
and then I just kind of always
maintained my alt my thing was always
well like well like I had this one coach
just challenge me like you're not a man
if you can't do three dips so I got up
to 30 dips and I quit playing football
like yeah I'm gonna go the wave pulling
me chicks third yeah I went yeah I went
waterskiing like two years ago for the
first time we're talking about sports
yeah I was in the I was I was in Spain
and you know we're we've gotten off the
boat and there was a boat that was
pulling his water skiing and I but I
couldn't the the boat wasn't that
powerful so you had to kind of hold your
pull yourself up a little bit yeah and I
think I dislocated both of my shoulders
really yeah I mean I have no it's just
it killed me but yeah you know what I
mean though like you're like oh yeah
you're not my age like it goes you just
start losing more and more strength in
your forties like it's just it's rated
so I literally just kind of but ya know
but then after that I literally always
went by the standard of no matter what
like in that Matt in any of my acid just
all my party and party and party in
drunken days I could always bench like
225 10 times that was yeah that was
always just like I could always do that
and then like and then for a couple
years there living
on here I just kind of was like you know
like in LA you're just bored in the day
and you're like I'll go to the gym yeah
the gym so then I was like every day on
my 20th birth it's why every time on my
birthday I'd do 20 Oh 20 to 25 yeah and
then like a couple years ago I was like
as long as you do that you're like well
I'm good to go next so yeah so then like
three years ago I did like 17 and I'm
like oh okay you got a little bit older
okay wait I didn't really work out much
this year and then like and then like
and then like after my hernia operations
I was just doing like I was like okay
I'm doing like 12 and like okay yeah 10
and then I go double-digit yeah yeah and
then like now I'm like I did I did 10
like the laughs I did ten like like a
couple months ago 225 is no joke that's
two plates on each side yeah but I mean
I did like I did I did like ten like a
couple months ago and then literally I'm
like you know I'm not gonna be pissed at
myself I'm just gonna night through that
I'm just gonna put like less weight and
just like because I know I can't do it I
know because I can just do the fact that
you can still do ten it by the way the
combine that's one of the things you
have to bench 225 as many times as you
write and that was almost guys get to
about 25 times and I'm like you being is
all you know your age just still being
able to do like 10 or 15 and never never
played in the NFL yeah also you like you
don't lift anything in between besides
like yeah the hotel gym I'll like lift
yeah but yeah but yeah well I always
yeah but like like my friend you have
like strongman so like my freshman year
a cop well I was work construction in
outdoors and I was a kid yeah and I got
like that Italian kind of yeah but I
always uh but my freshman year at gym I
took gym in college my freshman year huh
I did I benched 25 29 times yeah and
they're like there's and I was so happy
because there was like guys at the
combine daily like I'm a bit like 25 12
you're still you're still the size of a
guy and strength of a guy and and I mean
muscle muscle tone of a guy that if you
bump into you yeah it's like a wall
orders don't like me
[Laughter]
I'm not a violent person by any means no
but I'm saying like your your your
strength is still like you I just I just
got my I still got my like you never go
what you have shoulders you know yeah -
time it's my kids are gone has - brother
good all in construction he did
construction growing up he never left
never went to the gym once ever but
could when he shook your hand it was
like a vice grip right anything you had
ever had to pick up or left or hit he
could do it for like a Paul Bunyan type
and he just had that strong man strength
well know you got boys yeah so now a
number one has and I have a girl and
Mike the boo is just she she could be
she could be you know she could be just
she's she's so freaking strong cuz she
drinks milk all the time yeah and see
when I was a kid I just drank milk all
the time and I'm telling you kids that
drink two things ever in their entire
life and never doing anything besides
milk or water yeah kids a drink milk
they're the ones that can like they're
just you can just you can just tell it
to Park kids that drink kool-aid you can
just you can just I let their bones are
not me and that's why that's why another
job but that's why and then working
working outdoors labor when I was like
14 15 16 that's when you get that
strength in their places that you're
never gonna get by doing preacher curls
yeah taking up cinder blocks at weird
angles yeah with like the metal finger
cement cement bags yeah will barrels
like that's that's that's 50 pound bags
of peat moss we had we had skim milk
when I was a kid skim milk skim milk my
mom oh that's why you're pretty court
yeah we always had where his head skim
milk we always had the weirdest food my
house when I was a kid my mom had like
we had no like cookies no sweets or
anything
my mom had a drawer in her bedroom that
they had candy bars because my parents
were alcoholics and if they had all its
like candy and we would go in there and
sneak candy bars once in a while from
but we had to be careful we had to wait
when they had like a big supply and
they'd had a big night out so we could
you know we could go lift a couple oh
really oh yeah they knew we had
we had cartons of cookies and stuff none
of the drain ever Entenmann's nothing hi
different nothing we had she owes its we
had the only thing we found that our
parents side drawers was like porn and
you found porn in your parents side yeah
my dad's side drawer had a couple
Playboy's in it we found playboys we
found put what yeah and a vibrator did
that freak you out a little bit I didn't
know what it was but there was a back
massager you don't know what it is nor
older but poor and I knew what that was
you know but do you found it yeah I
found your mom's vibrating around it if
you told her that every pole you know we
have a good relationship what am I gonna
tell her I found her vibrator
by the way your mom listens to this
podcast that's weird man I can't imagine
like oh I can't even we were talking
about Nina well my parents had back
massagers no no my dad had a bad neck
[Laughter]
dad had a bad neck my mom had a bad
front but I mean we're just writing we
were talking we were talking about this
the other night I was talking to Neal
Brennan and Jimmy Carr we were talking
about how the fact that there's
something about like you never want to
see your parents have sex and the
thought of like kissing your sister or
something there's something about the
pheromones of a bob of a person that it
just becomes repulsive unless of course
you live in Mississippi but that's
natural that's Darwinism because that
means that you're not gonna make more
retail yeah they want yeah well that's
what I mean but it's that but that's
that thing it's that rate a [ __ ]
yeah well like I said except for
Mississippi now I was in Mississippi
those are nice people they're really
nice people little slow you were just
telling me before though about
pheromones and smells of people they're
certain people have smells that you just
can't shake though right like you you
all got a problem with someone that yeah
yeah yeah I have Santi really yeah that
person they just is like a moss tepee I
used to buy to them showering whatever
it's not about the showering I dated
this girl once this was years ago
this girl was [ __ ] beautiful and she
was like a yoga teacher and a fitness
instructor she still does fitness stuff
body insane beautiful girl I I was
repulsed by her smell like it wasn't a
body odor thing it was just the way she
smelled and I couldn't [ __ ] do it I
mean I tried man I tried so hard I mean
we slept together like three times no
I'm kidding you never slept together but
I mean it's just like I couldn't I
couldn't physically my mom smells so
good that's wow he said that with a
straight face so good that's the problem
she has great pheromones you know you're
right I think that's why you don't have
sex with your mom you don't you don't
the smell of you I mean it's just
there's a that there's a certain thing I
think there's certain people that you
just there's there just there's no
attraction there yeah you're very
tractor yeah exactly
are you attracted to people's armpits no
see I find myself at some girls I just
think their armpits are amazing and I
just saw this the other day somewhere
they were talking about that I'm like
finally someone else agrees with me
you're talking about like a shape in
there or like or just looking at the way
it looks
we're like in defeat I'm not in defeat
but I have but there's certain feet that
that I nasty feet or nasty feet yeah I
mean those those those those ones that
are all jammed up from from standing the
heels that look like you know look
they're just jacked man I can't handle
those feet they've got like horns all
own feet like tiny big oh no no I don't
like I don't like I don't like eating
fact that no armpits is like a thing I'm
trying to think like to me armpit this
it's so close to side boob that like
even if the armpit was attractive I'm
gonna check out to see if there's side
like side boob oh yeah was saying armpit
over ass for titties yeah I'm just
saying armpit is another thing to get
into yeah I don't even look at those
faces anymore I'm strictly about the
armpit now well yeah I mean that's the
whole thing it's like I have this
there's this one chick that's in that's
on redtube that has got the sexiest cat
and feet and she just takes it in every
[ __ ] direction really and she is I'll
show you I'll show you what we're done
here it's just so named do you know her
name
point it's a porn star right yeah Rachel
star no that so fast Oh everyone knows a
few yeah well I mean the last star last
time that we did a podcast or maybe he
came over but remember we were like
looking up Lindsey Vonn oh I still have
all those photos on my phone I'm afraid
when my daughters and look for like
pictures of the dog she's gonna like
what is know it's been a few podcasts
ago we cuz you know Tiger Woods had his
phone hacked or Lindsey Vonn had her
phone hacked and in I mean nice pictures
of Lindsey Vonn Lindsey don't look at
him as I feel terrible about it cuz I
just know that no one ever was supposed
to see those but I someone did pass the
Tiger Woods one to me I didn't see the
Tiger Woods one yeah he's definitely
more black than Asians he got a hog yeah
it's impressive he's not playing with a
3-wood no he's got a full driver I've
got a driver with an extra stiff shaft
it's one of those like super duper ones
that old men have you know the extra
like yeah Oh God that's funny because
yeah there's like certain like like porn
now to me like if you look at some of
the porn it's like I I have to see the
preview cuz I don't want to click on it
and that's why redtube is good because
redtube and it comes up on your iPad you
can preview the that the clip and all i
need's the preview yeah well I know but
it but they're only like 10 minutes long
anyway but but you can preview it so
it's like cuz all of them in the first
photograph they look amazing then the
minute you push on it it's like her face
it scared buzzard off a [ __ ] wagon I
mean they're just awful [ __ ] looking
which sounds like it sounds like it's
something an SCC coach would say yeah oh
yeah always preview always pre-punch
it's gonna dive into something and I
don't know like even if you just put
your mouse thing on it and it just like
shows like what that's all that's all I
want to see I just
see what does it leaves that girl and it
was the guy because I was so bored in
the south
half the time this trip they don't have
porn in hotel rooms anymore huh because
they just don't have it anymore
I obviously you know what some places
have like that erotic channel like
they'll have I'm trying to make like
that one with Mary way you know you turn
the TV it's like Mario Lopez and sick
yeah yeah yeah that whatever that was
yeah yeah they have like erotic erotic
viewing like whatever oh I don't know
how filthy the porn is it might just be
like Cinemax off course yeah like you're
not getting straight up like porn yeah
not like spectravision you know or
whatever no you're not getting that
you're not getting the the good angle of
when a gleich enters there's the anus no
I'm gonna bite at 11:00 so I did I have
it all the next day I mean I'm thinking
about like how much could that porn be
like twelve bucks
it's gotta be the Internet's cheaper oh
yeah everybody has their phone yeah no
no one even needs it it's it's like it's
like seeing a payphone I don't know like
spectravision I do feel here okay well
this was an inappropriate podcast do you
have ever left a phone like porn on the
phone like I've gone like washed it at
night gone to sleep woke up in the
morning like on the airplane like opened
up my thing and it's on like like you
know it's on like people can hear like
there was the last thing that was on and
the porns like terminal Oh at the
airport like you know I got whatever
like are you gonna show like your pad
like your your thing today and it's like
porn I've had that happen
well I gave I gave a kid on American
Airlines saw some nice of Fast Times at
Ridgemont High Sex and the sex on the
plane I was watched in Fast Times
original right like the ten year old
deck it said things are gonna get cut
out yeah probably I mean I did whatever
it was on the TV eating like yeah yeah
yeah it was on the TV and literally all
the sex scenes were in there like like
Bush boob everything fast I'm verse my
high but when he called him a dick it
was that in there like
you really dick it wasn't in there what
was the kid doing we were just elbow in
the kid like check this [ __ ] out he
wasn't he was just watching yeah the
whole time yeah dude I kids when you're
eight
once you see boob you'll stare at that
thing like my dog get the chicken like
look you know look at anywhere else
until yeah my son isn't checked in on
boobs yet but he's starting to get like
with like the different lady parts dude
I had that you know those Bluetooth
speakers like the Bose sound sound port
so I have one of those sits my living
room one night I was sitting there watch
you know listening to music you know
whatever and then I went my room and I
was going to bed and I put on the red
tube and I did and I didn't know that I
couldn't tell at first that it was
connected to the the Soundlink thing
that whatever the speaker and all of a
sudden I'm hearing this huh Wow
[ __ ] you know just you know the just
filth because I like to watch some
filthy [ __ ] and this was just filthy
it's normal that your house cool yeah
the neighbors were near they got courts
got another chick in there ah dude well
I told you the story about that my next
my neighbor upstairs you have an asian
girl that you were having yes yeah I had
this I had this neighbor upstairs that
used to have sex and she would kind of I
think on purpose kind of like put on the
show put on a little bit of a show make
a little noise put on it put on a little
bit of a show which is okay once in a
blue moon you know but it was like you
know alright enough already and then she
you know and so one night I had this
girl over that I made a lot of noise and
she was very verbal and loved to get her
ass smacked and I went to town and I had
all the windows open in my in my bedroom
on purpose and it was like a hot summer
night and I was just crushed and I was
just smelling hard smacking it hard and
I just you know the whole night the next
day I was in the hallway and the
landlord lives across the hall for me
the people at home the building she's
like oh my god
somebody last night did you hear that
they were just violently attacking this
woman yeah I think they had some kind of
weird porn on really loud look into it
and I was like no I was I was out late
then I came home went right to sleep I
didn't hear anything
me and my when I lived in the mission in
San Francisco the buildings are really
close you know it's like New York
buildings really close in the mission
and we had like a halfway house right
next to us so I'd always bang my
girlfriend with the windows up and I
like all the guys would get a free show
[Laughter]
barely hope they were all there it was
kind of like yeah they were barely
holding on the sobriety but you having
sex with your girlfriend was like you
see like six guys jerking up in the
window hey Josie oast got a girl tonight
all right everybody line up
daylight she's always worked at night so
I was like there's like you know night
it was daylight out oh god that's
fantastic yeah there's a get there they
always liked it it is good it's nice to
be kind and give back to people you know
it's it's it's called giving back yeah
you know you know I'll tell you one
thing you know and now there's gonna be
a plethora of all these superstars that
are gonna like go do telephones for the
flood so never know just write a check
don't you don't have to [ __ ] sing
just write a check
no one needs your unless you're Jerry
Lewis I don't need your [ __ ] telethon
you know and Jerry Lewis there is no
more Televisa think it's such it's such
a pat on the back oh really you're gonna
sing for the victims just write the
check you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean
look I don't mind going down like I know
Ron white went down there and did a
charity show whatever that is totally
different than feel like going on
national television television but
getting together to do that the telethon
seems to be like a it's not like no
there were people that didn't know about
this hurricane that's gonna watch
television and know this happened and oh
okay now I'll give money yeah nobody
knew about it I give Roy wait all going
there and doing a show and sure the
money that's a oh yeah I'm gonna go on
national TV and promote my new album and
here's my song well that's like me you
start looking at guys that really did
stuff like JJ Watt I mean I think that
guy collected like twenty three million
dollars yeah that's like amazing man
that's admirable and you know it was
gonna go to the right places but yeah
it's not gonna get you know it's not
like he's yeah I mean it's it's crazy to
me too because I was talking to somebody
that that has their brother lives in
North Houston and I was like is he okay
and he goes oh yeah he's just been been
watching binge watching Netflix for the
last like four days and I was like what
and I'm like well why doesn't he like
people are flying in to help people why
not all these people in North Texas
drive 15 minutes and [ __ ] help
somebody you know it's like there's all
these people out there that weren't
affected by it
and live like five miles away well what
do actors do on those telephones they
just answer the phones right there's
really nothing they can do they do a
scene like a monologue or something it's
always there in kind of yeah I think I
think Leo's gonna you know I don't know
I just think it's like you know it's
such a self-serving thing to do yeah I'm
sorry you know write a check don't go on
television and write or go down and help
people and write a check to somebody
that's actually gonna get the money
because most of these places like red
cross I mean I don't know what to do you
never don't want to push people in the
wrong direction be like hey give to this
or give to that but you like I don't
know like you hear bad things about
wounded warriors about Red Cross yeah
[ __ ] what am I gonna do with it with the
you know giving money away now well it I
mean it all goes back to like it started
with that woman that did that Susan
komen whoever does the breast cancer
thing with the NFL with you know it
started started out with their little
bracelets you know or whatever the bands
that they sold all that money all the
money used to go to breast cancer at the
time then they partnered with the NFL
and administration and there's
administration fees and it's like and
they in it I think it's like what is it
like 2% 2% of the money actually goes to
for the research offices criminals
flappers comedy shows giving money to
we did ro seeds of the tickets will go a
portion of the table portion of the
tickets well I think there's a deal
where it's like when you give to charity
because I remember we set up but we did
a charity once with wounded warriors we
did a Wounded Warrior thing and there
that whatever there's like you only have
to give like there's like just a very
small percentage for it to be considered
a charity now we took all the money and
we gave all the money to them but I mean
yeah but at weedless before everybody
kind of knew that Wounded Warrior maybe
wasn't as much on the level as they said
it was but I don't know I mean who fifty
I get fifty thousand things sent to me
every month you know here's a hat here's
a you know things with your address on
it here's a couple notepads it's like
well you guys spending all this money on
that [ __ ] for you know like right yeah I
don't need [ __ ] ten pages of my you
know name it dressed on it's like
because those people want jobs when
there's no when it's not hurricanes yeah
yeah that's true it's like the guy does
a sign language that guy was like I was
working his ass off this weekend it was
like taxi oh really well yeah he's gotta
warn the people that can hear yeah
everybody every press conference is like
30 people behind the guy talking and
then there was like I I watch like TV
I'll tell you Fox News has the best
weather maps like the hurricane I
watched some I watched some Fox News I
did I watched some of that in it was
better than the a they had the best maps
in town I thought the coolest thing was
the the Attorney General of Florida was
a hot chick in chief and she threw down
on 7-eleven could you know all those
tears are you know $30 for a case of
water yeah $32 per case well yeah the
terrorists atone 7-eleven but just like
let these white people die Jesus Christ
they were that's what a 7-eleven was
charging was $32 for a case of water Wow
a buddy might sent me a picture of a
Walmart in Florida like during like the
two days before the evacuation
was mandatory so people were stocking up
it looked worse than christened [ __ ]
Friday were 10 times worse I could see
them running out of [ __ ] but like then
to just have like a couple cases left
and then just price-gouging
yeah okay so I went after them so hard
that like you would ever like that they
had terrorists of 7-elevens or like
they're bringing truckloads of water for
free
oh yeah because she just went after him
it was like and she was hot I'm like
this is cool I was in there I was in a
hurricane shelter when I was a kid and
I'll tell you what I would never leave
my house oh you're saying you would
hunker down or what yeah I would never
leave you see how then the cops they get
all they all get all assholey they don't
let people back in their own
neighborhoods when you you give up all
your rights when you do that man you're
like you know you're signed in and you
can't leave and they tell you when it's
safe it's like go [ __ ] yourself really
yeah because it's like you have put this
way I'm a man I'm an adult yeah I should
be out there helping people I shouldn't
be some puss in a shelter
I should be [ __ ] helping people I get
that but then the only thing is like the
people that can't help themselves I'm
not saying the elderly now it's like
saying women that aren't lesbians you're
on your own you get your [ __ ] rav4
you get your friends together and you
drive yeah pump your own gas yeah their
dogs cancel all their big labs can swim
yeah no but no but literally I'm gonna
talking about the elderly I'm not
talking about women with kids I'm
talking about men okay I'm talking about
men you know come on you know I agree I
just I even for me I know like I
wouldn't know what to do if like the
[ __ ] the water just came I mean I'm
not saying I'm not saying I could
survive like you know man vs. wild
survive no I'm saying I'm saying you
know get him out leaving your stuff I
don't even give a [ __ ] about my stuff
I'm just saying it's like you know I'm a
good swimmer I get a life vest a couple
gallons away in a couple [ __ ] cases
of water it's like I'm gonna survive
yeah but the pain it's like that's not
the problem the problem isn't it
happening you saw it in some of these
places where you know you've got a tree
like that that that blows down and
crushes the house and crushes the people
in it then you've got a power line down
so the water is actually electrified so
I mean that's where that you know and
then there's the drowning where you
can't get out of someplace and that's
that's the problem the problem isn't you
give water cool sockets right like the
ground well that your are you [ __ ]
doesn't know wasn't why you're thinking
well know what's gonna happen is it's
gonna it's gonna short out but you're
gonna have power lines that come down
yeah and the power lines if you're close
to that then you're you know yeah but
the biggest problem isn't necessarily
the you know it's drowning like if you
were to get like a wave were to come in
and take you know take something out and
you get caught underneath you know a
wall or you get caught or nice something
that's that's the problem that's what
they're trying to avoid right or not
right and I'm saying I will take that
chance
I telling you it's like it's like and I
know it's like saying okay I'm gonna go
to jail I'm safer in jail yeah I'm sorry
you know it's like yeah I said instead
it's going like to a ho like I wouldn't
want to be in a hotel just hoping that
my [ __ ] was still there like that would
be terrifying to me like just being in a
hotel waiting and hoping that no Steve
you know though cuz you have kids what
you have kids do you really [ __ ] care
about anything no I mean it's like I
don't it's not even the thing about I
don't I just like I don't want to be
subjected to some to some Dade County
Sherriff's idea of where I'm supposed to
be and what I'm supposed to know that
comes down to with me I live with people
that care about some [ __ ] though - yeah
nobody are you saying maybe your wife
and kids I could see my daughter over
and I yeah I know I just I I think about
like just sitting there like those
people like I just hope when we get back
we're allowed back in or [ __ ] still
around or accessible or right but we
used to I mean we just have to all the
time we used to have to evacuate
when I was a kid for tornadoes because
we would have to leave that we'd have to
leave the house and we would go to our
friend's house that had a basement and
we would do that all the time we weren't
go to a like like you're talking about
like a shelter with a hurricane shelter
is basically like you know when you're
in the airplane and you landed but you
can't but yeah
so some stewardess has the power of
[ __ ] Jesus Christ you what to do I
would chance recently what a hurricane
shelter I would show someone that just
tells ya I know and no [ __ ] way no
you know [ __ ] you you know alright [ __ ]
you Irma yeah I'm a G being stuck in
like this like a like a dome Stadium
with like ten thousand other refugee
people yeah all the best was like
telling you like the best was the video
I don't know if you saw the video too
people [ __ ] in a hurricane shelter
what in Texas there's a there's a
YouTube video of two people just totally
under the under a blanket just [ __ ]
the best of it yeah I got no problem oh
yeah I don't know I have a funny story
about a hurricane shelter though right
so first so that the shelter was funny
because me my cousin for some reason
showed up late or whatever we're like
where they got my parents we're late for
the hurricane well yeah it's coming
early teenagers and they weren't gonna
listen we're gonna sign in like we
weren't there in time and my you know
five foot nothing Italian mother just
[ __ ] lost her marbles like just great
see I love seeing like Angie wonder twin
powers activate like when a engine goes
and goes it's amazing but but the funny
the real funny part of the whole night
was so you know yeah pay attention
you're playing miniature golf you're
everyone's having fun vacation and yeah
so we went to like this all you know
those old places in like Myrtle Beach
where it's like all-you-can-eat country
dinners yeah
like the Golden Corral yeah but it's
like you know like aunt Maggie's house
or whatever [ __ ] so my dad ate like so
many baked beans who started his own
hurricane yeah so bad and the lines were
so long that he would just go and
immediately just get out and get back in
line oh god it was like a turnstile get
as much out as he could let the levees
breathe a bit and then go back at the
end someone's walking this talk on all
Jesus yeah Jesus I'd rather go outside
and deal with mother nature
oh I got a good story about going
outside other than another podcast
podcast hey listen buddy it's great to
have you on the pot the bad boys we're
best we appreciate you having us in your
home and we're so I'm sorry your dog
[ __ ] in your kid's room it's alright it
happens and the wife cleaned it up he
comes in we come in from golf we're
hanging out crap bad he might take a
crap he takes it just a it's disgusting
I thought somebody had killed somebody
and then and then his wife comes home
Tracy comes back she's in there she goes
uh Mickey [ __ ]
diarrhea [ __ ] in Jonah's room and
Steve's just looking at phone texts and
he goes oh that's made sure that wasn't
me no I think I got it all in the ball
and she's just picking up stuff gonna
clean it up and he says and she's like
I'll clean it up he's like okay thanks
[Laughter]
listen great to have you on the podcast
what do you got coming up this week this
week oh I'm going to San Diego to the
kaboom Music Festival in Del Mar Norma
Connells on after me I'm excited I
haven't seen norm and forever and then
pink at night it's nice nice nice and
the Red Hot Chili Peppers are out Friday
night I'm pretty sad Sunday night oh
right on
Tom Petty's Aussie yeah you got anything
coming up this week buddy
this week no no not this week not this
week this week you know la [ __ ] yeah
yeah I will be yeah this week I'll be in
El Paso Texas with Pablo Francisco if
you are anywhere near there and are dry
oh that was nice come see us you can
check out all my stuff at Court McCowan
at Joe bartnick at Steve Rannazzisi at
Steve Rannazzisi this is in sensitivity
training
I'm court McGowan I'm Joe Clark Nick
have a great week have a great week have
a great week
have a great